Дуже сподобався вчитель
і манера спілкування.
Я ж не знаю, треба буде
подивитися, Настя Каменських буде?
Привіт! Я Петро
Чорноморець, вчитель біології,
співавтор демократичної школи «Майбутні»
Сьогодні ми з вами поговоримо про смаки.
Які смаки знаєте?
Це ж просто.
Я не зрозуміла зміст питання.
Які смаки знаєш?
Музичний смак.
Супер. Фізіологічні.
Тобто те, що ми сприймаємо
завдяки смаковим цибулинам на язику.
Ну, там солодкий, гіркий, оце все?
Кислий. Що ще?
Терпкий – це смак?
А зараз обговоримо.
Гострий, солодкий, солоний.
О, давайте так, чому з’явилися
сумніви, що терпкий це смак чи ні?
Тому що це схоже на
відчуття, а не на смак.
А що означає відчуття?
Ну як відчуття на дотик, наприклад.
Тобто – терпкий більш схожий на відчуття?
Це між смаком і відчуттям на дотик.
Ага, добре, супер.
Ну давайте ще раз. У нас був
солодкий, кислий, гіркий, солоний, терпкий
І музичний.
Ну, музичний – це інша історія.
Ну все. Ще?
А ми маємо всі знати чи ви щось підкажете?
Ну от дивіться. Ми розглядаємо не з
точки зору, що я вас чомусь навчаю.
Ми розглядаємо як ми живемо в реалії.
Чим відрізняються різні продукти
для вас. От які в них є нюанси смаку?
Ну, вони гіркі або солодкі, або солоні.
Або ще є хурма, яка в’яже рот.
Ну, це відноситься до терпкого. А чи
може бути смак приємний або неприємний?
Це вже емоційна оцінка.
У нас є сенсорні відчуття, тобто
те, що приходить від органів чуття.
Давайте поговоримо.
Чим, наприклад, відрізняється
цукерка від лимону?
Смаком. Вона солодка, а лимон кислий.
Добре.
А чим, наприклад,
відрізняється м’ясо від яблука?
Я вегетаріанка.
Можу сказати, що яблуко – це фрукт,
а м’ясо це м’ясо.
Чи Ви на смак маєте на увазі?
В чому різниця смаку яблука і м’яса?
Ну, яблуко солодке, а м’ясо солоне.
Дуже складно сказати смак,
тому що воно може бути різним.
Типу гострим або солоним.
І мені складно описати смак м’яса.
А от для м’яса є характерний смак?
Описати смак сирого м’яса я, наприклад,
не можу, тому що виходить що пробував.
А візьмемо навіть готове
м’ясо, тобто, наприклад,
у нас є варене чи смажене
м’ясо з сіллю і є каша теж із сіллю.
А Ви маєте на увазі м’ясо
солодке, солоне чи ще якесь?
Ну тут складно.
Ну імовірніше воно ближче до
солоного, тому що ми його солимо.
А так смак я не можу описати.
Від солоної каші ще
чимось воно відрізняється?
Ну гарне запитання.
Консистенцією відрізняється.
О, супер. До цієї штуки теж дійдемо.
Коли ми говоримо про їжу, ми
можемо казати, що є щось про смаки.
Ми ще розберемось.
Є ще органолептичні властивості.
Тобто, яка вона нам з
точки зору тактильної,
з точки зору механорецепторів у роті.
І там щось може бути хрустке або
м’яке, або ніжне, або м’ясне, наприклад.
Але, знову ж таки, м’ясо з консистенцією.
Добре, візьмемо котлету
м’ясну або м’ясний фарш,
якийсь м’який, ніжний і
такої саме консистенції кашу.
Однаково ж є різниця, правда?
Так, звичайно. В чому?
Тому що котлета буде зі смаком
котлети, а каша буде кашею.
Виходить, що ми знаємо смаки речей і,
наприклад, коли ти береш шматочок яблука,
і кладеш собі на язик, то
ти розумієш, що це яблуко.
Бо ти знаєш цей смак.
Також із м’ясом.
Ти знаєш, що це смак котлети,
але описати його складно.
Я не знаю, не пам’ятаю смак котлети.
Але ж ти однаково сою їси? Бобові?
Вони ж відрізняються від каші? Гриби?
Так, звичайно.
І в принципі бобові та гриби чимось
схожі на м’ясо за своїм смаком, правда?
Я не пам’ятаю, якщо чесно. Можливо схожі.
Просто м’ясо взагалі дуже давно
їла і вже не згадаю його смак.
Але Анатолій знає, що
бобові та гриби вони,
як і інші продукти з великим вмісту білку,
вони мають свій специфічний власний смак.
Тому під час посту перше,
що вигребли – це горох.
Тому що люди відмовляються
від м’яса і замінюють його горохом.
Тепер відомо, у кого
запаси гороху. Будь ласка.
Насправді, ми знаємо чотири класичних
смаки – це ті, які ми вже назвали:
кислий, солодкий, солоний та гіркий.
Ми маємо багато варіантів
відчуттів, які насправді смаком не є.
Це, наприклад, терпкий, гострий, свіжий.
Прісний – це рахується?
Про прісний зараз поговоримо.
Які ще є відчуття, чим
ще може відрізнятися їжа?
Ну, гарячий і холодний може бути смак?
Так, теплий.
Ну, мабуть, це основне, що нас цікавить.
Але ми з вами забуваємо
принаймні ще про однин смак,
його просто відносно недавно відкрили.
Він називається умамі.
Як?
Умамі або м’ясний.
Умамі на кухні. Ми знаємо цю пісню.
Це називається м’ясний смак. Він окремий.
Є окремий рецептор для цього смаку.
Гляньте, чому ми кажемо, що
ось це смаки, а ось це не смаки?
Тому що тут діють якісь інші
рецептори, які не є смаковими,
а тут діють конкретно
смакові рецептори на язику.
Тобто, умамі – це новий?
Чому ми про це не знаємо?
Дуже довго вважали його неважливим.
Дуже довго ось ці рецептори
вважались класичними.
А умамі забезпечується саме
білками і якщо ви знаєте,
така дуже відома штука: «А
їжа, в ній глутамат - це жахливо»!
Насправді, глутамат – це амінокислота,
така як ми їмо з будь-яким білковим
продуктом
і це основне джерело смаку умамі.
І якщо купити чистий глутамат
– це просто білий порошок,
ми з дітьми робили, і
його розвести у водичці,
покласти трохи солі, і
виходить м’ясний бульйон.
Серйозно?
Навіщо відчуття смаку?
Щоб розуміти, що не
можна їсти, а що можна.
Що смачно, а що зіпсоване?
Думаю, це на рівні захисних
властивостей організму,
коли організм сприймає,
що це можна їсти, а це ні.
Якщо воно гірке, то його не варто
їсти і підсвідомість тобі підказує.
О, супер.
Я напишу так.
Ось всі ці штуки – це
варіанти хеморецепторів.
Це рецептори хімічних речовин.
Тобто у нас є багато
варіантів хеморецепторів
І вони нам потрібні навіщо?
По-перше, щоб не з’їсти щось шкідливе,
тобто захиститись від чогось шкідливого,
з іншого боку – потрібні для
того, щоб знаходити щось корисне.
Тобто те, що ми наситились, ми відчули
трохи пізніше. Ми відчули багато смаків,
у нас розтягнулися стінки шлунку.
У нас підвищився рівень цукру та
амінокислоти в крові – це буде пізніше.
А на старті нам лише потрібно
зрозуміти, що це високобілковий продукт,
а білки в природі дуже потрібні.
Для того, щоб нормально почуватися,
нам потрібно отримувати
певну кількість білків.
Тому умамі нам дуже подобається.
Добре. Тобто дивіться.
Солодкий – це про
енергію, умамі – це про білки,
гіркий – це про те, щоб
побачити якусь небезпеку.
Тому їх дуже багато видів,
саме рецепторів гіркого.
Солоний і кислий – навіщо?
Кислий, можливо, для того, щоб теоретично.
Щоб отак робити.
Що у нас кисле? Кислий – це,
наприклад, не фрукти, які ще не достигли.
Вони ще кислі, і,
можливо, це попередження.
Про сирість продукту говорить. Готовність?
Так, стиглість.
Можливо.
Але насправді всі ці штуки – ми не
знаємо як воно з’являлося еволюційно.
У нас є певні гіпотези, де –
десь вони більш підтвердженні,
десь менш підтвердженні.
Стосовно кислого є цікавий факт, що ми
смак води визначаємо рецепторами кислого.
Тобто ми дізнаємося, що п’ємо саме воду
завдяки активації
збудженню рецепторів кислого.
А каву?
Кава, імовірніше, - там буде
рецептор гіркий і терпкий.
До нього ми зараз теж дійдемо.
Тому кислий, можливо, - це про
стиглість, можливо, це про вітаміни,
або, можливо, це про воду.
Коли нам не вистачає
води, тоді ми хочемо кислого
І це остання гіпотеза,
яка підтверджується тим,
що кислий із солоним непогано співпадають.
А солоний – це про що?
Це те, що ми хочемо пити?
Навіщо нам солоний смак?
Складно сказати, незважаючи на те, що
в природі солоних продуктів не так багато.
Ну, хіба що коли нам
хочеться кам’яної солі.
Можливо, це лише у людей є чи ні?
А насправді більшості диким
тваринам, їм не вистачає солі,
то вони спеціально ходять за 30, 50
та 100 км на солончаки, щоб її полизати.
Насправді нам людям
вистачає солі в своєму раціоні,
а для більшості тварин їм
дуже не вистачає натрію,
тому вони його всюди шукають і
тому солоний смак дуже важливий.
І разом солі натрію та водичка –
це основа водно-сольового обміну,
тому вони працюють часто в парі.
Звідки ще енергію беремо крім
швидких та повільних вуглеводів?
Спати треба чи це не рахується?
Це відпочинок. А ми
маємо на увазі конкретні
речовини, з яких ми
отримуємо.Скажіть? Жир.
І це дуже важлива штука,
особливо для вегетаріанців та веганів.
Для того, щоб у нейронів
були правильні оболонки,
ну зараз не будемо впадати в дрібниці,
можливо, почитаєте про
шваннівські клітини, мієлін і т.д.
Тобто всі ці штуки, щоб правильно
працювали,
нам потрібні саме насичені жири,
які лише є у продуктах
тваринного походження.
І їх треба якось добирати, якщо
людина сидить на вегетаріанській дієті.
І риба теж не підходить, тобто мається
на увазі лише теплокровні тварини.
А якщо їх не добирати, то що буде?
Поступово відбувається
демієлінізація для нервових волокон
Це якась деградація?
По суті так. Тому маленьким
дітям категорично не можна.
Я просто не пам’ятаю тебе, коли
ти їла м’ясо і я не знаю, якою ти була.
Я ось така була!
Ти ж їх звідкись добираєш?
Треба подивитись, яка дієта і
можливо ти звідкись добираєш,
але на це є сенс звернути увагу.
Для маленьких дітей нестача насичених
жирних кислот призводить до кретинізму,
тобто там взагалі все критично.
У дорослих на деякий час є.
Запаси старі.
У нас же власного жиру достатньо.
Ось звідки я черпаю. Можливо.
Тобто худі люди більш схожі на кретинів?
Ні. Якщо нормальна дієта,
то все нормально буде.
Але тут нам не вистачає жирного смаку.
І стосовно людей досі не
знайшли рецепторів жирного смаку.
Але ми знаємо, що більшість ссавців
мають такі рецептори на язиках,
тому, ймовірніше, і у людини також вони є.
Або, можливо, є гіпотеза інша,
що люди про жирний дізнаються
завдяки активації механорецепторів,
тобто за консистенцією якраз.
Це те, що я казав -
органолептичні властивості їжі.
Ну, зачекайте, вода з маслом
теж жирна, але не тієї консистенції?
Вона буде інша. Вона
буде на дотик відрізнятись.
Але точно ми зараз не знаємо,
але у більшості ссавців
є рецептори жирного
і ми припускаємо, що у людини
також є, хоча поки що їх не знайшли.
Але можливо там органолептичні
властивості також впливають.
А оці всі штуки. Це все не смаки, тому
що тут нема специфічних рецепторів.
Ну найбільше мені подобається – гострий.
То якщо ми говоримо про гострий
смак, то це активація больових рецепторів.
І тому, наприклад, якщо перцем
натиратись, то також буде боляче.
І якщо нормально наїстися
перцю, то назавтра на виході пече.
Чому?
Тому що ті ж самі речовини залишаються,
вони всюди на больові
рецептори впливають однаково.
Також частково гострі речовини
активують ще теплові рецептори.
Тому температура важлива.
По-перше, температура важлива,
тому що всі смаки ми краще відчуваємо.
Якщо їжа має температуру
близьку до температури нашого тіла,
тобто 35-40 градусів, то це
оптимальна температура їжі для смаку.
Це якщо не дуже якісь специфічні страви.
Але у нас є гострий смак, він
обманює теплові рецептори,
тобто він одразу активує
і больові, і теплові.
А свіжий, наприклад, ось м’ята
вона стимулює холодові рецептори
і це також варіанти обману,
по суті, якихось рецепторів.
Ну, мабуть, найскладніша
історія з терпким смаком.
Там що відбувається? Там специфічні
речовини, які називаються таніни.
Вони зв’язують компоненти нашого
слизу, які вкривають всі слизові оболонки.
І це призводить до того, що слизова
оболонка стискається і висушується.
І через це у нас декілька різних аспектів.
По-перше, ми суттєво гірше
починаємо відчувати всі смаки,
а по-друге, оскільки вся слизова
оболонка стисла і висушена,
вона гірше працює цілком, і це впливає
і на нижні шари, наприклад, стравоходу.
Через це, якщо добре наїстися хурми,
потім взагалі не вдається ковтнути.
Знайоме вам таке?
Це так страшно.
А в мене бувало.
Це ти ніби задихаєшся.
Знаєш таке?
Так, я знаю і це жахливе почуття.
Так, це жахливе відчуття.
Але потрібно знати.
Що оскільки там є
таніни, то воно так буває.
І що робити? Просто не панікувати?
Менше їсти хурми.
Мені це не підходить. Їсти «шарон».
Так, я їм «шарон». Я пам’ятаю,
коли я вперше спробувала хурму,
я була дитиною, то я взагалі
не зрозуміла що відбувається.
Я подумала, що я розвалююсь.
Так, діти лякаються.
А що відбувається зі смаком,
коли у вас закладений ніс?
Ой, це жахливо, адже ти не відчуваєш смак.
Але ж це на язику, тобто
кислий і солодкий ти відчуваєш.
Я не дуже вже пам’ятаю, але пам’ятаю,
що коли я захворіла і був святковий стіл,
а в мене був нежить і все що їла, то
не відчувала смаку – все було прісним.
Але все не було прісним. Воно
було кислим, солоним, солодким.
Смак ти точно відчувала.
Але в чому проблема?
Чому ми при закладеному носі не
відчуваємо і їжа стає не класною?
Це якийсь самообман, я не знаю.
Можливо, ця інформація чомусь
не передається до нашого мозку.
Тобто при хворобі у нас нерви
перестають передавати інформацію?
Ну, можливо, смакові
рецептори нейтралізуються?
Смакові ні. Смакові залишаються.
Смакові можуть нейтралізуватися,
якщо людина кокаїну багато нюхає.
Ось тоді може бути
відключення смакових рецепторів.
Але якщо ми говоримо про
людину із нежиттю, то такого не буде.
Смак ми відчуваємо нормально.
Але якщо ми всі рецептори
і смакові, і побічні,
всі перерахуємо, навіть
зважаючи на всі гіркі,
то в нас вийде близько
40 різних рецепторів,
які дають нам інформацію,
із них 30 із гаком – це гіркий.
Тому взагалі про смак ми дізнаємось
із дуже малої кількості каналів,
тобто дуже мала кількість рецепторів.
Це загалом, а прикольних, - нам
же гіркий не подобається, крім тоніків.
Але це окремі виключення.
То загалом у нас до 10 рецепторів
– це ті, які нам подобаються смаки.
А нюхових рецепторів
у нас близько 350 штук.
Ось, будь ласка!
І тому аромат їжі дуже важливий.
Тобто їжа ароматна, але без
смаку – це теж не прикольно.
Наприклад, їсти туалетний папір.
Зі смаком полуниці.
Так. Це перші декілька
разів прикольно, а далі ні.
Але насправді нюх дуже важливе значення
відіграє для сприйняття не тільки того,
що ми нанюхали, а й того, що ми їмо.
І дійсно, коли у нас
нежить, то світ втрачає сенс.
Так, свої фарби втрачає.
Наприклад, чули про таке,
як вомероназальний орган?
Чув. Що це? Ну, я вирішив
просто підтримати Вас.
А про феромони?
Так, звичайно.
Що таке феромони?
Це те, що приваблює, якийсь секрет.
Це якісь молекули, які секретуються
організмом і вилітають у повітря.
Вони, як правило, несуть
значення привабливості.
Якщо говорять про феромони,
то не кажуть, що вонючі
феромони, тобто якщо
феромони, то це щось приємне.
Насправді ми їх не сприймаємо
на рівні усвідомленому.
Тобто те, що у людини є якийсь запах,
то це не феромони, а це просто запах.
А феромони ми не
вловлюємо на свідомому рівні.
Але наш вомероназальний орган також
поруч з нюховими рецепторами знаходиться
і він сприймає ці феромони, і за ними
ми визначаємо чи підходить нам людина,
чи не підходить з точки
зору хімічної та біохімічної.
Тобто це дійсно правда?
Так.Є така система МНС
– це англійською або українською – це
головний комплекс гістосумісності (ГКГ).
Це взагалі рецептори імунної системи,
але ці рецептори також визначають те,
кого ми обираємо або не обираємо як пару.
І ці рецептори частково спрацьовують
як раз у вомероназальному органі,
коли ми відчуваємо феромони іншої людини,
а частково вони
спрацьовують при поцілунку.
І тому буває така ситуація,
коли людина дуже подобається,
потім перший поцілунок і все – не цікаво.
Це тому, що спрацювала
система ГКГ і сказала,
що ця людина біохімічно
тобі не підходить.
А буває навпаки? Що ніби не
підходить, а після поцілунку так.
А чому цілувалася, якщо ні?
Зачекай, я не про себе. Мені
подруга розповідала. Старша.
Насправді може бути навпаки.
Це не означає, що ця
людина ідеально підходить.
Це означає, що наша біохімія,
а краще сказати імунологія,
тобто наші імунні властивості,
а конкретно головний комплекс
гістосумісності,
вони підходять одне одному.
Все. Ми за характерами можемо взагалі не
підходити, а за цим комплексом підходити.
Для шлюбу деяким людям цього достатньо.
Якщо людина ідеально
підходить за характером,
але не підходить за цим, то
просто, імовірніше, не буде кохання.
Тобто з цією людиною буде
все класно, тепла дружба,
але не буде почуттів яскравих
Тому що для почуттів потрібна ця система.
Ну, не єдина вона, знову
ж таки, це один із факторів.
А насправді багато, які нам
потрібні. Але це важливий фактор.
Давайте затримаємо подих.
О, давайте. Я думала Ви цього
ніколи не попросите. Нарешті!
Всі разом робимо глибокий вдих.
Це змагання?
Я би ще тримався, поки не гепнувся б.
Як ви знаєте, що треба зупинитись,
що досить затримувати, треба вдихати?
Знову ж таки, з’являється
напис: небезпека.
А звідки вона з’являється?
Мозок напевно.
А як він дізнається?
Ну, напевно, починається
кисневе голодування.
А як про це дізнається мозок?
Він розумний
Ну, дивіться, ми говоримо,
наприклад, машина.
І машина 2000 року випуску.
Ми до неї підключаємо комп’ютер
і там ми можемо визначити,
наприклад, два параметри. Все.
І підключаємо до сучасної
машини, а там буде двісті параметрів.
Чому така різниця?
Більш сучасний автомобіль. Якісніший.
І в чому різниця? Комп’ютер,
який ми підключаємо однаковий.
Що в машинах відрізняється?
Програмне забезпечення. Начинка.
А начинка яка?
Електроніка.
Програмне забезпечення це на нашому
комп’ютері стоїть, яким ми читаємо.
Ми одним і тим самим комп’ютером читаємо.
Але одна машина нам може
давати два параметри, а інша - двісті.
Залізо різне.
От що означає це залізо?
Там різні датчики.
Тобто у першої машини два датчики стоять,
я у сучасних стоїть багато датчиків.
Так само у нас ці датчики.
А що таке датчики з
точки зору фізіологічної?
Як це називається у тілі?
Яке це слово?
Рецептори.
Ну, не обов’язково «хемо», але рецептори.
Тобто ми з вами звикли
спиратися на класичні органи чуттів.
Насправді у нас у тілі дуже багато різних
рецепторів, про які ми просто не думаємо,
не знаємо і можемо їх
навіть свідомо не відчувати.
Але у нас є рецептори
РН, тобто кислотності крові,
є рецептори кисню крові,
є дуже багато рецепторів.
Є рецептори того ж цукру в крові.
Тобто у нас дуже багато і
хеморецепторів, і інших рецепторів,
які знаходяться у
внутрішніх органах, і вони,
по суті, регулюють те,
як ми з вами живемо.
І ми знаємо коли і як
дихати завдяки тому,
що є набір рецепторів у
нашій кровоносній системі,
які знають як все працює.
І це дуже важливо.
Тому хеморецептори у
нас не лише на язику і в носі,
вони є всюди в нашому тілі, і вони
виконують дуже багато важливих функцій.
Так само якби спрацював парктронік.
Ні, парктронік – це фоторецептор.
Він про світло дізнається.
І давайте останнє запитання.
А які рецептори дають нам
розуміння, що ми наїлися?
Які рецептори? Не знаю. Рецептори ситості?
Ситість – вже програмна історія.
Можливо, це рецептори,
які знаходяться в шлунку?
Так і що вони мають дізнаватись?
Що в шлунку є їжа.
Тобто це механорецептори в шлунку, що ще?
Бо інакше якби ми напихали, знову
ж таки, туалетний папір у шлунок,
нам би теж здавалося б, що
ми наїлись, але так не буде.
Тобто смакові рецептори
в шлунку також є виходить,
що вони визначають
що це не папір, а м’ясо.
Є деякі хеморецептори
дійсно у шлунку, а ще чому?
А чому смакові рецептори
не можуть з цим справлятися,
що у шлунку є смакові рецептори?
Достатня їх кількість у
роті, а далі сигнал до мозку.
Ти можеш пожувати і виплюнути,
і шлунок не подумає, що ти сита.
Але нас цікавлять
хеморецептори не ті, які в шлунку,
а ті, які знаходяться в
кровоносних судинах.
Тобто у нас є механорецептори шлунку, у
нас є хеморецептори травної системи і є…
Фоторецептори?
Ні. Фоторецептори це інша історія,
це парктронік або у тебе – це очі.
Нас з точки зору їжі це мало цікавить.
Добре. Просто хотіла
похизуватися цим словом.
Але з точки зору того як
ми розуміємо, що ми наїлися
- це набір хеморецепторів
у різних структурах тіла,
а також механорецептори шлунку.
В принципі далі можна
будь-яку систему так розібрати.
Ми беремо і аналізуємо,
які рецептори потрібні
для того, щоб тіло про себе зрозуміло.
Ми з вами сьогодні розібрались з
різними рецепторами нашого організму:
зі смаковими, нюховими, набором
різних специфічних хеморецепторів
та рецепторами внутрішніх органів.
З вами був Петро Чорноморець
- вчитель біології та співавтор
демократичної школи «Майбутні».
Так круто.
Ти слухав музику в цей час?
Дуже цікаво. По-перше, мені подобається
підхід, тому що якийсь розслаблений.
Чудові відчуття, давно забуті.
Сьогодні я міг це відчуття відпустити
і отримувати класні відповіді
на дуже цікаві питання.
Рецептори, завдяки яким смаки розрізняють
і розуміє наше тіло, напевно так.
Коли закладений ніс, то відчуття смаку
пропадає і теж в цьому рецептори задіяні.
Вони якби не працюють, коли немає
нюху. Це жахливо, в мене таке було.
Ну вегетаріанцям як раз
не вистачає смаку м’яса,
за який відповідає
нещодавно відкритий рецептор.